اعلنت نقاط اطباء السودان سقوط عشرات
القتلى والجرحى في مواجهات مسلحه بالجنينه
غربيه دارفور وصفها الجيش بانها صراع قبلي
وقد قال مني اركو ميناوي رئيس حركه جيش
تحرير السودان ان الحركات المسلحه قررت
تحريك قوه عسكريه للفصل بين المتحاربين
بالتعاون مع السلطات المحليه وكان وزير
الدفاع قد اكد ان الحركات المسلحه تقاتل
الى جانب الجيش
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
النقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي ظروف
والملابسات التي قادت الى التحول الصراع
بين الجيش والدعم السريع في غرب دارفور
الى نزاع قبلي والى اي حد تحسب طرف بل
يحسب طرفا النزاع بهذا الاحتمال ما هي
امكانيه تنفيذي ما كشف عنه من ناوي بشان
تشكيل قوه من الحركات المسلحه للفصل بين
المتحاربين وفرص قبول الطرفين نزاع بهذا
التوجه الى اي حد ينظر هذا التطور في غرب
دارفور بتمدد الصراع بين الجيش والدعم
السريع الى اجزاء اخرى من البلاد واتخاذه
ابعادا مختلفه وما تاثيراته المحتمله على
مسار النساء
[موسيقى]
بحسب تصريح لنقابه اطباء السودان فان
عشرات القتلى والجرحى سقطوا في الاشتباكات
التي اندلعت منذ نحو اسبوع بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في مدينه الجنينه عاصمه
ولايه غرب دارفور قبل ان تتحول هذه
الاشتباكات بحسب الجيش الى مواجهات قبليه
قال انه يعمل على حلها بالتعاون مع
السلطات المحليه وحول طبيعه هذه المواجهات
افادت مصادر محليه للجزيره بان الجيش
وحركات مسلحه اشتبكوا مع قوات تابعه للدعم
السريع لدى مهاجمتها مقر حكومه الولايه
وعلى خلفيه اشتباكات الجنينه التي اعرب
المبعوث الاممي للسودان
عن قلقه ازاءها وازاء اتخاذها ابعادا
قبليه قال رئيس حركه جيش تحرير السودان
مني اركوميناوي ان قيادات الحركات المسلحه
قررت تحريك قوه عسكريه مشتركه للفصل بين
المتحاربين بالتعاون مع السلطات المحليه
لمنع ما سماه توسع دائره الانفلات خصوصا
في دارفور رئيس حركه العدل والمساواه وزير
الماليه السوداني جبريل ابراهيم حذر من
جانبه من اتساع نطاق المعارك الى مدن اخرى
في دارفور ودعا لوقف اطلاق النار ياتي هذا
رغم تصريحات وزير الدفاع السودانيه التي
اكد فيها ان الحركات المسلحه تعمل مع
الجيش والقوات النظاميه الاخرى جنبا الى
جنب للدفاع عن تراب الوطن وحمايته من كل
التهديدات بحسب قوله
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع سينضم الينا لاحقا
السيد او عفوا ينضم الينا من الخرطوم
الجميل الفاضل الصحفي والمحالي السياسي
ومن مدينه ليستر في وسط انجلترا الصادق
علي النور المتحدث الرسمي باسم حركه جيش
تحرير السودان جناح مناوي وسينضم الينا من
الدوحه الدكتور صلاح الدين الزين الخبير
في الشان السوداني مرحبا بكم جميعا السيد
الصادق علي النور كيف تقيم حركتكم الصراع
الدائر بين الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
وما موقفها منه
طيب شكرا لك على التحيه لمتابعين قناه
الجزيره شاكر لكم على الاستضافه حركه جيش
تحرير السودان
لديه موقف صعب الفتره الطويله فيما يجري
في الساحه السياسيه السودانيه
الى تحول ديموقراط حقيقي وجينا
الى وبدانا في كيفيه هذه الاتفاقيه وبعد
ذلك استمرت
المناكفات بين القوى السياسيه الموجوده
الى ان وصلنا الى 25 اكتوبر وما تداعياتها
بعد ذلك انتقلنا بعد 25 اكتوبر الى تعقيد
المشهد السياسي بصوره اكبر وقدمت حركه
السودان في ذلك عبر كتله الديموغرافيه
ورؤيه واضحه
الانتقاليه وحل الخلافات العالقه بالقوه
السياسيه المختلفه ولكن هذا الصراع او هذا
الخلاف بدا تتشعب وتتوس حلقاتها والى ان
وصل الى مرحله ويسمى بالاتفاق الايطالي
وكانت الحركه تنذر بذلك وتنبه الطرفين بان
تتوافق وان تسيرا في اتجاه وموقفكم منه
الان السيد الصادق اذا سمحت لي موقفكم من
هذا الصراع الان كيف هو
تماما نحن وقعنا الاتفاقيه ملتزمون بوقف
اطلاق النار حتى الان وملتزمون في مواقعنا
التي تم تحديثها قواتنا موجوده في لم
تتحرك ونحن ملتزمون في هذه المرحله لكي
تهدي هذا الوقت
والوصول الى حوار شامل تفضي الى وزير
الدفاع السوداني قال بان الحركات المسلحه
تعمل مع الجيش والقوات النظاميه الاخرى في
غرب دارفور ما ردكم هل هذا واقعي
هذه نقطه مهمه جدا اولا هنالك في
الاتفاقيه جدا هي تشكيل قوات مشتركه
لحمايه الامن
في الاتفاقيه بالنص لذلك هذه القوه التي
اشار اليها وزير الدفاع يقول التي تم
تدريبها تخريجها من اجل الحفظ في حفظ
الامن في اقليم دارفور لذلك شاركت هذه
القوات باعتبار انها تحت مسؤوليه القياده
المشتركه او اللجنه الامنيه المشتركه
المكونه من القوات النظاميه وقاده حركات
الكفاح المسله هذه القوات ليس لديها علاقه
بقوات حركه الكفاح المسله الوقت لديها
واضحه ما زالت موجوده لم تدخل في
الترتيبات الامنيه هذه القوات لوحدها فما
القوات التي شاركت ذلك الذي تم تدريبها
وتخريجها ودخلت في القوه المشتركه التي
تتكون القوات النظاميه والقوات الحركه
وحركات المسلحه السيد جميل الفاضل كيف
ترون تحول الصراع بين الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني الى قبلي في الجنينه وغرب دافور
من الطبيعي ان زلزال الحرب الذي وقع في
الخرطوم في الخامس عشر من ابريل ان تصبح
له هزات ارتداديه في
اقاليم اخرى من السودان وربما ان الاقليم
الاول الذي يمكن ان يرشح لهكذا هزات
ارتداديه واقليم دارفور باعتبار ان كافه
المكونات التي تشكل الان عناصر حركات
الكفاح المسلح الى جانب قوات الدعم السريع
والتمر حول الذي مرت به هذه القوات من حرس
الحدود الى ان بلغت هذا المسمى الاخير
تحدث التناقضات في المسرح السياسي
السوداني وتقود لان تصبح هذه القوات تصنف
كقوات متمرده ومعاديه للجيش هذا هذا هذه
التركيبه ايضا
اتوقع ان اقليم دارفور بمثل ما حدث في
الايام القليله القادمه في مدينه الجنينه
ومدينه الجنينه بالمناسبه في اقليم غرب
دارفور هي بمثابه قنبله اجتماعيه موقوته
اعتقد ان الاوضاع فيها قد تم ترتيب بشكل
خاص خلال فتره نظام الرئيس عمر البشير
خاصه في العام سته وتسعين وقد اشرف على
هذه العمليه الفريق محمد مصطفى الذهبي الى
جانب الوالي غرب غرب دارفور محمد الفضل
تمت عمليات هي التي خلقت هذا الواقع
الواقع هذا الواقع متفجر ظل منذ الاربع
سنوات الماضيه تشهد هذه الولايه وربما
ولايه وسط دارفور الذي خرجت منها كثير من
الاحداث المشابهه وتحدث فيها صراعات دمويه
قبليه
واعتقد ان الان بنزع قطاع غطاء الشرعيه
بقرار حل الدعم السريع ايضا هذا اغرى كثير
من الاطراف
يمكن ان نقول بانه تصفيه حسابات الامس مع
هذه القوه هذه القوه جاءت على خلفيه ان
هذه الولايه قد شهدت تغيير ديمقراطي
ومساله تهجير قصري
ومساله احلال وابدال
للسكان او استيطان من جهات كثيره يدور
حديث عنه وتدور اتهامات حوله انا اعتقد ان
هذه هي كانت تحتاج الى شراره ماء اعتقد ان
هذا التحول في الموقف من الدعم السريع من
قبل السلطه الرسميه قد اتاح لمن ارادوا
وظلوا يضمرون هذا الامر لماذا طويل
باعتبار ان هذه القوه كان يقودها نائب راس
الدوله وانها تعتبر قوه في اطار دستوري
وشرعي وقانوني الان ربما وجد البعض ضالتهم
في هذا الظرف الاستثنائي وبالتالي ايضا
التحركات نحو احتلال اضاءه مقر رئاسه
لو صحت الروايه هذا يعني ايضا ارتطام بقوه
يقودها الوالي خميس هو ايضا من الموقعين
على اتفاق السلام لذلك اتصور انها حركه
المناصره التي اتت من قبل السيد منيوي
تاتي في هذا السياق باعتبار ان الولايه
نفسها هي من حصه او انصبت الحركات المسلحه
واضح وفضلا عن ان هذه التركيبه السكانيه
التي صنعت قبل نحو 27 عام هي ايضا لها
تاثيرات كما يحدث الى السيد الصادق عليه
النور طبعا السيد ميناوي تحدث عن تشكيل
قوه مسلحه من الحركات المسلحه هل كل
الحركات المسلحه وافقت على تشكيل هذه
القوه سيد صادق
دعينا نقول معك دقيق جدا في هذه النقطه
بالذات قائد من لا يوجه بتشكيل مشتركه
ولكن في مدينه الفاشر على وجه التحديد
القوه التي والتي قامت
بحمايه وتسهيل اجراءات نقله داخل قوات
حركه الجيش
لجنه من الولايه مع
القوات المسلحه الاخرى لذلك انه هنالك بعض
الحركات وافقت مبدئيا بالمشاركه ولكن
المشاركه الفعليه كانت من حرق السودان
لتامين المقر وتامين البئسه من اجل اجلاهم
بالامس مساء
الامسيه واليوم الصباح تم اجداد 12 فرض
دخول اكتمل الدرس ترحيلها بان ترجع هذه
الدعسه الى عملها
يعني للتوضيح اكثر
القوات او الجماعات الاخرى لم توافق على
تشكيل هذه القوه وقوامها يقت صر الان على
حركتكم صحيح
هي وافقت فقط مبدئيا ولكن الموافقه
المبدئيا بالمشاركه ولكن القوه الفعليه
التي شاركت في ادلاء الرايه كانت في
القوات حركه الجيش تحرير السودان الدكتور
صلاح الدين الزين ينضم الينا من الدوحه
دكتور كيف ترى تسميه الجيش السوداني ما
حصل في الجنينه بانه صراع قبلي هكذا قال
بيان الجيش السوداني قبل قليل
شكرا جزيلا لاستضافه طبعا يجب ان ننظر لما
حدث في الجنينه ليس فقط في سياق الازمه
الحاليه الاشتباكات بين القوات المسلحه
وقوات الدعم السريع وانما في سياق اوسع من
ذلك كما تفضل الكريم من الخرطوم وهو ان
هذه المنطقه ظلت ملتهبه
فقط للتذكير العام الماضي تقريبا قبل اقل
من عام كانت الاوضاع الامنيه سادت الى
درجه ان السيد الفريق حميتي نفسه ذهبا
واستقر لفتره هنالك لمحاوله
لتهدئه الاوضاع والسيطره الاوضاع بمعنى
اخر ان سرعات لها جذور تاريخيه وجزء كبير
منها ايضا مرتبطه بممارسات يعني نسبت
لقوات الدعم السريع اتجاه مكونات سكانيه
معينه مما ادى لانه
ارتدادات الازمه الاخيره وبدء فقدان قوات
الدعم السريع لوضعيه فيما يتعلق بصيراتها
بالسلطه القائمه انه الامور تبدا في هذا
الاتجاه لكن انا في تقديري انه بامكان
تلافي هذا النوع من
الازمات التي تهدد الامن المجتمعي اولا
بالرهان على وعي قيادات
القبليه والمحليه المدركه لانه اي
التهابات بهذه بهذا المستوى
سيؤثر على استقرار المنطقه وعلى امن
سكانها وعلى اوضاعهم بصوره عامه ايضا
السلطات
الموجوده محليا وولائيا وحتى مركزيا عليها
ان تنتبه انه
المعركه الان مع قوات الدعم السريع عندما
تنتهي ستكون هنالك يعني بؤر قد تنشا فيها
يعني نوع من الاحتكاكات وبالتالي لا بد من
التحرك لاحتواء مثل هذه
الاحتكاكات اخذ ذم في الاعتبار الممارسات
السابقه المرتبطه احيانا بقوات الدعم
السريعه السيد علي نور ما حدود التدخل
التي يمكن ان تذهب الي هذه القوه
المشتركه هل يمكن ان تشتبك مع طرف
مع طرف ما
لوقف الانفلات كما كما تقول حركتكم
ساعيد السؤال ما حدود التدخل الذي يمكن ان
تذهب اليه هذه القوه المشتركه التي اعلنها
عنها السيد ميناوي هل يمكن ان تشتبك مع
طرف ما لوقف الانفلات الذي قال بانه
يسود الان في مناطق معينه في غرب دارفور
طيب هو طبعا هنالك شيئا مختلفين تماما
هنالك قوه مشتركه زي ما ذكرتيها لم تتكون
القوات حركه المسلحه وقوات النظاميه هذه
القوه لوحدها هو كحاكم اقليم موجه بان هذه
القوات تعمل مع القوات النزيما الى جنب
الى تهدئه اما قوات حركات الكفاء المسلح
الذي لم تدخل في ترتيبات الامنيه لهذه
ليست ملوطه بها في الدخول في الاشتباكات
والقوات الاخرى هي مهمتها فقط حمايه المقر
وحمايه الممتلكات المدنيين وحمايه والدفاع
عن ممتلكات المدنيين الى حد الاشتباك
من ضمن هذه المهام تصل الى حد الاشتباك مع
طرف ما
ليس هي الذهاب
ولكن في من اج الحمايه لابد طبعا هناك
لابد من استخدام القوه من اجل الجماع اذا
كان هنالك
ميليشيات وتفلته تعتدي على ممتلكات
المواطنين على المقام مقر الحكوميه مقارنه
العموميه لا بد من
المواجهه اسمح لي السيد ملاوي قال للفصل
بين المتحاربين يعني البيان كان واضحه او
حتى التغريده على تويتر كانت واضحه قال
للفصل بين المتحاربين ولوقف الانفلات
الامنيه هل هذا يصل الى حد الاشتباك مع
طرف ما في حال يعني وصلت وصل هذا الاقتتال
الى الى منطقه معينه يرى بانها ضمن نفوذه
مثلا
نعم هذه ليتنا
تمت قياد
ات المصلى للتواصل
الحديث الذي قاله
الممثل الحركه بالخارج لكن في الحقيقه
التغريده تعطي هذا المؤشر وهذه وهذا
المعنى اي تدخل من هذا النوع ما بين
الطرفين الجيش والدعم السريع اعتقد انه من
الصعب القيام به دون رضا وثقه وموافقه كل
الطرفين عندما نتحدث عن قوات سلام او قوات
للفصل بين قوات في حاله حرب هذا يقتضي
ايضا نوع من الاتفاق بين الطرفين
المتحاربين على قبول وعلى الثقه بالطرف
الثالث الذي يقوم بعمليه الفصل واعتقد ان
هذا لا يتوفر الان في ظل هذا المناخ
الحركات الموقعه على اتفاقيه جبل بالصمت
لزمن طويل هذه الحرب الان اخذت اسبوعين
وبالتالي هي لم لم تقطع برايي في هذه
القضيه بشكل واضح واعتقد انه في الحرب
الحاليه
قالب الاطراف ترى بانه يعني لا توجد منطقه
وسطى ومن ليس معنا فهو ضدنا يسود منطق مثل
هذا وبالتالي ان اعتقد ان حركات جبهه
حركات المواقع على اتفاق جوى يعني طال
الزمن او قصر لا بد ان تسحب اقدامها الى
المواجهه وحينها سيكون الامر مختلف بطبيعه
الحال اعتقد ان هناك رواسب تاريخيه هناك
حاله من الاحتقان والقبله التاريخي تجاه
قوات الدعم السريع التي اصلا توصف بانها
هي قوات الجنجويد وانها هي قوات حرس
الحدود وانها هي التناصورات مختلفه الى ان
بلغت هذه الصيغه الشيء الثاني تعامل قوات
الدعم السريع خلال الازمات السابقه او
خلال الاحداث التي تفجرت في دارفور ظل
يذبح جناحها الى حد كبير ان انها جزء من
السلطه وان قائدها هو الرجل الثاني في
الدوله واعتقد ان بحلقه باعلان حلقات
الدعم السريع
بازاحه ورفض استمرار القائد قائد كره
الدعم السريع هذا يعني يمكن ان تصبح يدها
اكثر طلاقه في التعامل الميداني وترى بانه
لا توجد قيود
تجعلها تتعامل او يتعامل قادتها كرجال
كرجال دوله اصلا الان ستعود هذه الحركه
الى مربعها الاول وستنطلق وفق ما تريد
وفقي مع التشاب بالاساليب التي عهدتها
وعرفتها واورثتها كثير من السجلات التي
تؤخذ عليها في حروب دارفور منذ العام 2003
وين اليوم دكتور صلاح هل ينظر هذا التطور
بالجنين على ان الصراع فعلا
انتشر في مناطق اخرى في الخرطوم ويهدد
ربما ايضا مناطق قبليه اخرى
قبل الرد على هذا التعليق سريع في ثواني
على موضوع نشر قوات الحركات المسلحه
المشتركه في في موضوع الفاشر تحديدا في
الفاشر تحديدا كانت هنالك هدنه اصلا
بمبادرات محليه ادت الى ايقاف المواجهات
ما بين قوات المسلحه
وقوات الدعم السريع منذ العيد تقريبا
وبالتالي هدات المواجهات المباشره ولكن
ظهرت ظاهره اخرى وجود بعض
اللصوص والمتفلتين الذين يستهدفونه
ممتلكات الاشخاص وهذه اوجدت حاجه ضروريه
لوجود قوه امنيه ايضا تحرس المنشات في وجه
هذه التفلتات واعتقد هذا اللقام فيه قامت
به القوات حركه التحرير السودان اتفق جدا
مع الضيف من الخرطوم انه التدخل للفصل بين
المتحاربين لا يمكن ان يتم الا بتوافق مع
الطرفين المتقاتلين بمعنى لا يمكن الحركات
المسلحه ان تدخل الا اذا توافق الطرفان
على وجود من يفصل بينه وهذا ليس متوفرا
الان بالنسبه لاحتماليه انتشار هذا النوع
من الصراعات التي وقعت في الجنينه في
مواقع اخرى في دارفور انا يعني كما ذكرت
ان هنالك شعور بالظلم والغبا تجاه تصرفات
الدعم السريع في عدد كبير من مناطق
الدارفور النتيجه لممارسات السابقه ولكن
هنالك ايضا وعي لدى القيادات المحليه سواء
كان قيادات محليه سياسيه تنفيذيه او
قيادات قبليه وقيادات مجتمع بضروره الحفاظ
على الامن المجتمع وعدم السماح لانفلات
الامور
يعني توجيه دائما الاتهام للدعم السريع
بمعزل عن الجيش مع ان الدعم السريع كان
يعني هو من ضمن الجيش وهو من الاطراف التي
وقعت على الاتفاق الاطاري وهو يعني بطبيعه
الحال هذا ليس له علاقه بالاتفاق الاطار
هذا يتعلق انا لا ليس بالضروره الاتفاق
الايطالي بحد ذاته ولكن الدعم السريع هو
مكون من الجيش لكن
كقوه ارتبطت منذ ايام الرئيس السابق كثير
من التصرفات التي اضرت ببعض المجتمعات
المحليه وربطت وليس بالجيش والرباب قدر
كبير بسلوك القوات الدعم السريع وهنالك
بعض المجتمعات بحكم انها تحالفت او قريبه
جدا من قياده الدعم السريع واعتبار انه
الدعم السريع كان يمثل الدوله بشكل رسمي
وصل الى نائب رئيس الدوله رئيس قائد الدعم
السري هذا اوجد حاله يعني من القبول
بالامر الواقع في ذلك الوقت لكن انا الذي
اشدد عليه ان احتمالات نشوب ازمات محليه
تبقى وارده ولكن الوعي المحلي الموجود
شعور القيادات المحليه سواء كان من زعمات
القبائل القيادات الدينيه القيادات
المحليه في قطاعات مختلفه لتدارك هذا
الامر وعدم السماح لمناطقهم بان تنزلق في
اتون معارك محليه هي يمكن تقريبا
هذه الحركات
بتركيبتها
لا تخلو طبعا من التاثير القبلي حتى في
مقاتلها لا يخشى ان يتحول هذا المقترح من
السيد ميناوي وانا اقصد هنا هنا القوه
المشتركه التي اعلن عنها بان مشتركه للفصل
بين المتنازعين الا يخشى ان تصبح
وتصب مزيدا من من الزيت على النار الملتهب
اصلا في هذه المنطقه
اصلا لا يمكن ان يحدث ذلك
هذه الحركات
نظري من فتره طويله هي تعرف جيدا اين تكون
المشكله واين تكون الخلل واين الحل كذلك
هذا الصراع الان التي ظهر في السطح انا
ارى كثير من الناس تركوا حقيقه الامر او
اساس المشكله وذهبنا بعيدا لافرازات
المشكله التي نراها في دارفور في سواء
كانت الفاجر او في الجنينه المشكله تكمن
المشكله الحقيقيه تكمن في عمليه السياسيه
التي ظلت
مستعصيه مستعصيه الحلول في في المركز الى
ان ادى الى انفجار هذا الوضع مش طبيعي جدا
التعنت الذي ظهر من القوه السياسيه في
المرحله الماضيه والم قبول الاخر وعدم
قبول الراي والراي الاخر هي التي ادت الى
شكرا هذا الوضع طيب اذا اذا ذهبنا الان ان
نتحدث في في في مكان الامر نجد بان هذه
القوات طبيعه تكوينها سواء كانت قبليه هي
تركيب السودان هذه هي سواء كانت في
الاحزاب او في الحركات او في القوه شكرا
لك الصادق علي النور من مدينه ليستر في
بريطانيا شكرا لك شكرا للجميل الفاضل في
الخرطوم وشكرا للدكتور صلاح الدين الزين
في القاهره عفوا في الدوحه شكرا لكم جميعا
الى هنا تنتهى الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر الى اللقاء بامان الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]